And what is going to be about
procalcitonin? We are going to teach it at
Dr. Javier as a specialist in
real preciosas, head of section and the
same as Ignacio Arribas, head of the
clinical biochemistry service. We
work in a
Ramón y Cajal university hospital. The
educational webinar  today is presented by the
brooks and sponsored
is a leading in vitro diagnostic company
i would like to remind you that this
7 event
and we are going to participate in it
whatever questions you want during the
presentation to do so just
write
the box
click and we will
answer  all questions that
at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble viewing or listening to
the presentation click the
support tab at the
top right of the
presentation window or let us know by
clicking the ask a question box
located  on the far left of your
screen
this presentation offers
training credits  Continuing
Education Click on the Continuing Education Credits tab
at the
top right
The process to earn your
credits below begins with a
presentation from a mine from
a plus point of view.
Procalcitonin is synthesized in the
cells of the thyroid gland from
From a precursor that is procalcitonin,
this peptide undergoes its own lysis
by a peptidase and is released.
The name of mine itself was known
and it consists of 116 amino acids.
releases the calcitonin hormone
subsequently the prosthesis nodule gives
rise to our peptide which is known
from catacaos
in infection or sepsis situations
there is a synthesis of broken cytosine
of the quality in the organization is to
treat the idea in particular
stafford calcitonin does not undergo
proteolysis no  is sensitive to
reactivation, therefore in these
situations there is a typical increase
in  citrulline itself but not
calcite
life authority itself is a
fairly stable loss with a half-life of
more than 24 hours and therefore
relatively easy incredible great just
introduced a
minimal chemiluminescence assay method per
tim instance that we  The organizer architect can come, it
has a reference value that
is usually below 0 1 in chili peppers
and in situations of severe infection, it
can take being the first to say
times about the based value
, the procacity is not clearly known, it already
has a solution  or not, but it is known that
the control rises in response to a
toxin. It was seen after injecting in
technology, obtaining a group of
healthy volunteers, seeing that the
application had increased
around 4 24 hours. It is thought to be
median inflammation similar to the  cytokines
in experimental animals, it has been
seen that procalcitonin injection
clearly increased mortality
while  It produced a
prophylactic neutralization with
antibodies, which was achieved was an
increase in the survival of these
animals.
The clinical utility of procalcitonin
is double, on the one hand, it is that it increases
in bacterial infection
and, on the other hand, it is used to assess the
efficacy of antibiotic treatment.
ggal of bacterial infection and 2 and
of infection and inflammation the first
initial evidence was based on the fact that
in British bacterial studies,
on the other hand, it must be
remembered that being a
variable itself
can also offer different cut-off points
than a  In turn, they offer different
results of diagnostic quality in
terms of sensitivity
in a study carried out in
adult patients admitted to the
intensive care unit of the Princess Study Hospital.
When we applied a
cut-off point of 0-5 provided by the
caller, we obtained a positive LR of
when the  point was euro with 6 which
was the value of the median result  Results
of our study in a
logistic regression study we were looking for
parameters associated results of only
independent
sepsis we saw that procalcitonin
when it was that they had a value greater
than four times three times the patients
[Music
] sepsis the subsequent study a
systematic review
[Music  ]
it was seen that the cut-off value of the
hill of 05
1 negative 0 0
at the cut-off point 2 students went up
in the re-positive increased
significantly almost double 56 and
with this same cut-off point when
looking for the efficacy of several
combined variables of positive his life in a spectacular way as
long as among the
dominated males there was always the
capitality in fact here fandós a
device of greater than 10 which is a
result
and then I give way to doctor
Javier so that some utility
but peaceful
and good my  My name is Javier Cobo and I
work as head of the
infectious diseases section at Hospital
Ramón y  cajal
bueno attending as a consultant
infectious infectious problems in
the hospital environment today we are going to
talk about procalcitonin as a
tool in the management of
antibiotic treatment
in daily hospital practice
we are faced with patients who
have symptoms and signs that suggest
an infection but that can also  not
be, patients may have a
fever, which may seem to us, for example, that
this could be an infection, but it is not
always. Many patients have a
lot of microbiological information,
positive cultures that can
express contamination, colonization, or
also be an infection, and this also
happens.  In patients who have
diseases, conditions that predispose
to infection or that can be complicated
by infection, all of this generates, as
you can imagine, a scenario of
uncertainty in which one
often sees it in daily practice, what does it
mean in these cultures in this
patient?  No  What do we
doctors have to try to solve these
scenarios of uncertainty? Clinical judgment,
experience, clinical examination
, anamnesis, and also microbiological criteria.
Traditionally,
microbiology reports some cultures with
bacterial counts with more than ten to five
formal colon units and  more than
ten to three in a wash, anger when
flying, well, these are criteria that help us
and, above all, we have managed ourselves
for many years, with
biological markers at the forefront of which
are leukocytes in
peripheral blood and formula or protein
c-reactive and really little else we have
had to make decisions regarding
the use or not of antibiotics
in patients,
thus, for a few years now, the
possibility of having a new
biomarker for infection, which is
procalcitonin, has arisen if you pay attention
if it is  do a search on paper
you will see that there are more than 200 publications
a year  Only by selecting procalcitonin in the
title, it is
practically impossible to keep up to
date, therefore you must give us an idea
of ​​the tremendous volume of information we
have on procalcitonin
with any biomarker with any
diagnostic test, one can consider
how useful it is in diagnosis and
prognosis  In treatment,
the diagnostic question is how useful
is this biomarker, procalcitonin,
in diagnosing sepsis or a
bacterial infection. As a marker of
bacterial infection, which is from
a prognostic point of view, one would say that
having a very high tonin appropriation
is a worse prognosis.  or it means but
prognosis for the patient or if
procalcitonin does not drop, the test would be useful
in the field
of infection prognosis and finally, I think it is
very interesting,
we can also ask this biomarker to be useful for us
to see decisions regarding the
discontinuation of antimicrobial treatment  Iotic
is a bit what I am going to try to
summarize throughout the talk. To
begin with, it is necessary to know how in
any biomarker its kinetics and its
characteristics. Procalcitonin
differs from c-reactive protein in
that it is more sensitive and specific but
also in  its kinetics the kinetics in
procalcitonin is closer
to the pathophysiological events
that are occurring in the patient,
notice that in this graph the
bullish axis is not a normal axis and the
works go 12 6 12 24 so that
this graph would really have  We had to go through the
wall of this room so that
we could see the true
dimension of these curves, with this
caveat, you can understand that this
procalcitonin curve is much earlier and
also drops much earlier
than the c-reactive protein does, therefore
It is closer to the events and to the
pathophysiological events that are
occurring in the patient,
its half-life is between 20 and 35 hours and
then  go It is also important to know
some aspects of its elimination and to
know, for example, that it is eliminated in
continuous renal replacement replacement techniques
with venous hemofiltration
as a whole biomarker is not perfect
and has false positives and false
negatives that must be known to
interpret  Well, in the clinical context
in which we are going to use it,
the main false negatives for
procalcitonin are localized bacterial infections,
for example,
sinusitis, osteomyelitis, we should not
expect it to have high levels
of procalcitonin,
there is also information that is somewhat
contradictory or difficult to ascertain.  interpret
neutrophilic patients in areas such as
endocarditis and we must also
know that in the first hours
a sepsis if we have a patient who is very
well monitored and suddenly
develops sepsis, it may be that in the
first hours procalcitonin still
has not risen to  ranges nothing let's say
that we  Let's assess it as
pathological
and also, as happens with the rest of the
biomarkers that I have already mentioned,
we have false positives, as you can see
in the image, because they are related to
clinical situations in which there is
inflammation of another etiology other
than infection, as occurs in a
multiple trauma patient after  large
surgeries or external burns sorry
for extensive or also in patients who
have serious disorders such as
cardiogenic shock or multi-organ failure
of another origin therefore good because it must
also be known that an
elevation of glycation toniná by
definition does not always necessarily indicate
infection and  these are limitations of the
test that will mean that both its sensitivity
and its specificity are not 100%
[Music]
there are many studies and trying to
delimit the precision of
procalcitonin in the diagnosis of
sepsis
in a 2007 meta-analysis,
a  area under the curve of 0 79 with those
like chose king uncle positi  vas and
negatives that's good, those values
indicate to us, let's say so, they placed it as a
test of moderate precision, although
a slightly more recent meta-analysis has
improved the parameters a bit,
we are already in the area under the curve of 0 85 it is
quite good it is always  It is difficult
in a disease like sepsis, which
also does not have a perfect standard goal, to
say how sensitive or
specific it is, but well, in general, the
idea that I see is that I can convey to you
that it is a reasonably accurate test
for the diagnosis of sepsis.
studied more in some areas
than in others, for example, that
meningitis, pneumonia or
respiratory infections are the very area of
sepsis, we have many more studies and more
evidence than in other areas, at the
other extreme we would have
joint infections where their
usefulness is probably less but  We also
have less evidence and then
there, as you can see in the image, well,
other entities where we have  There is a lot of
information, such as urinary tract infections,
pancreatitis,
or other types of
respiratory infections that you have not mentioned, so
good, I also think we have to
know this idea that appropriation
is already more studied in some syndromes
than in others, it
is a marker of infection.  but it is a
marker
of infection of systemic infection as you can see in this
image if we go from what would be in
the old terms of the
systemic inflammatory response syndrome
rising towards septic shock the
patients are having more and
more systemic expression,
procalcitonin also rises in  its
determinations there is a lot about this
overlap sorry there is a lot of
overlap between the determinations
in an electron domain but you can see that the
tendency is clearly that it blocks
cyclin is higher the more
systemic expression or more systemic damage
there is produced by the infection
therefore it would have a prognostic value  in
the sense that c  The higher the
procalcitonin, the worse because it indicates
that there is more compromise of the host or more
systemic involvement. Undoubtedly, this
has been looked at and you see that, let's say,
higher procalcitonin levels
generally cause worse prognoses,
however, it does not seem very reasonable to
establish the prognosis for
patients.  Based on this biomarker
or on others, we really have clinical markers,
clinical prognostic indices, and
here you have them in this specific case of the
mod, but there would be others such as the sofa,
etc., which promises they will be finer
than a pure determination of a
biomarker, so it does have prognostic value.
Although it is not the
ideal tool to restore it, from my point
of view, the prognosis
could also be established not only by
how high the biomarker is, how
high the procalcitonin is, but also how it
decreases, and in this sense,
we also have information that shows that
more decreases  defendants, for example,
over 80  percent
four days compared to patients who
do not have an 80% drop
once you treat the infection in four
days the survival curves
separate are different so the
faster the
procalcitonin drops specifically we can
remember this this margin of  more than 80
percent in four days according to this
study because the patient would have a better prognosis
there are many studies that have tried to
establish a specific parameter and say
if the patient drops
procalcitonin more than 50 percent
in 72 hours well you see that each
article  Each author has searched
for slightly different parameters of decrease percentages
and slightly different cut-off points,
but if you want a
bit of a global overview of this table
that compiles the many studies in this
regard, perhaps we can stay with the
idea of ​​approximately a 50
percent decrease.  cent at 48 and 72 hours would be a
marker of good prognosis and not
reaching it would be  a marker of worse
prognosis this is undoubtedly useful
in the management of critically ill patients
in intensive care, where
sometimes it is not easy to assess the response,
the patient is still dependent on vasoactive drugs,
still has a fever, perhaps we
still do not have microbiology and the
truth is  having a stereo
marker in 48 hours with a
marked decrease would be,
let's say, a help to be
calmer that the patient
temporarily antibiotic
is well chosen
but really what from my point of
view procalcitonin has been a little
different
I would highlight as a biomarker is  that
beyond the fact that we have been able to study
how sensitive specific is a bit
the usual questions that one
asks a biomarker how good it is to
confirm or deny the diagnosis of sepsis
how much it rises to how much it falls at
what rate those questions that  more or less
we have been answering
the great virtue let's say of the
investigation that has been  done with pro
paz and toniná is that clinical trials have been done
this is unusual we
do clinical trials with
drugs not with interventions with
drugs this is an intervention
with a laboratory analysis
this is original from my point of view
and it is something that confers  An added value
to this biomarker is what has been done to
try to answer the question of how
the fact that we have procalcitonin available for a specific patient affects clinical practice. It
is a different question
from how specific it is sensitive because
the test could  be very sensitive or very
specific and not have any impact in
real life because we were able to
manage the patient independently and
the availability of that test
then the attempt to answer this
question is particularly
original and interesting from the point of view
that they are  clinical trials with an I
commanded
I believe that all the clinical trials
that have been done with pr  ocalcitonin, which
are many, have been made with a design
like the one you can find in the
image
for doctors,
or rather whoever is authorized, it
is not for doctors, it is for patients, but
once the patient is
randomized, they can get two  branches
not the standard management, that is to say to you,
a patient who has pneumonia, your
doctor will manage you as he has done
all his life, as he
is capable of doing, due to his own practice, or on the
contrary, he may leave, you may have been
randomized to the group  experimental, which
in this case means that the doctor
treating that patient does so,
say, with the help of
procalcitonin and that doctor or those
doctors are given an
interpretation of procalcitonin, a
kind of rules that are not
strict rules if they are not  recommendations or if
the provocation is if the
procalcitonin is very low, do
you think that perhaps it is not a
bacterial infection or that this
infection is bac  teriana has already been resolved, if,
on the contrary, procalcitonin is
high, it would be the opposite and in between there are
some parameters, let's say, of a
recommendation that is not so strong, not so
intense,
but it is important to remember that in the
end, the doctor always
logically has freedom as it can
be otherwise  The way in this type of trial
to make the decision that seems most
appropriate to you this is not randomized that
if your procalcitonin is 0-1 you will be taken
off the antibiotics it is
randomized that your doctor has
that information it is important to remember
a  little that good design because with this
design a multitude of clinical trials have been done as I say
this is one of the
most powerful it was published in llama in
2009 and let's say well more than
1000 respiratory infections of
which it is important to emphasize that almost
1000 en  to pneumonias of which, as
you can see, 50 percent were
pneumonia in four or five external cases, they were
not jokes, nor to patients who were hospitalized.  italize
bani who had a serious infection
and I think these graphs are very
expressive in blue the
percentage of patients who remain
with antibiotic treatment
over time is shown and in white are the patients
randomized to
conventional management and in blue procalcitonin
can  It can be observed, for example, on
day 5 there are already many patients, a
percentage of around 40 percent
who are no longer receiving antibiotics
with a diagnosis of pneumonia, while
obviously ninety-something
percent of the patients who
corresponded to the standard group and
standard management they were still using
antibiotics, you can assume that here there is a
much, much decrease in the consumption of
antibiotics that is seen in pneumonia but
is seen in COPD or other respiratory infections.
Overall, in this study there was a
saving of three and a half days
on average  let's say per patient in the
case of pneumonia and not so
marked decreases but also significant  atives in
other types of infections, having
fewer and fewer adverse effects produced
by antibiotics
with this design, and as I said,
there are a multitude of similar studies and
studies with similar results, it would be
a step further and they went to the field
of intensive care.  the same, because it is
also very commendable what it is to
tell the intensive care doctors
we are going to update your patients whether
or not you have procalcitonin the
design is identical
in this case they are critically ill patients with
sepsis of whom it is true that
most  Part of the patients had
respiratory infections and once again
a decrease in the use of
antibiotics was found without any
change in the parameters, let's say the
evolution of the patients, mortality.
Well, I didn't say it in the previous study,
but obviously there was no
difference in  mortality or between
admissions or any relevant clinical parameter,
space management, that is,
and  According to these
clinical trials, we are achieving the same results
with less use of antibiotics
and even in this study,
surprisingly, favorable differences were even seen
in the group of
blocks and tonina. Mortality was not
easy to explain, although some hypotheses could be made,
but in
any case.  Of course, it was not worse to
be randomized to the procalcitonin group. You can
see that, for example, in
this study they tell us that
strict adherence to those tables in
which, according to the values ​​of procaz and toniná,
it was recommended to suspend or not
antibiotics are not by far the
majority.
In other words, 44% strictly followed the
protocol, no, this does not
mean that a doctor who, for example, today
does not suspend the antibiotic because
procalcitonin has reached 0 10,
maybe if he removes it tomorrow, that is the
reality, it impacts the  Let's say in
the global consumption of antibiotics or in
the cycle of antibiotics that each
patient receives and g  globally therefore there
is some decrease
not all the studies that have been done
with these designs or with
similar designs have found the same
results
this is a different design in which
let's say that procalcitonin was
used strictly daily without
any clinical criteria but simply
for  routine to all critically ill patients
and the authors do not find
any benefit or savings from the
antibiotic, if not all the studies
that have been carried out have found
these results, perhaps by design
because let's say that here there is a greater
systematic routine action of
procalcitonin  Surely it sometimes makes a little
senseless and it is possible that
we can say that this separates a little from the
routine of medical practice in which
one requests diagnostic tests with
an intention and not in an
absolutely routine and systematic
way, so that in the field  of intensive care
finally if we have
a meta-analysis  where, as you are going to see
in the graphs, it is confirmed by the
majority, there are some studies where
the statistically significant difference is not reached,
but
overall, let's say from this meta-analysis
of 78 studies, it does show a decrease to
not as marked as the one we saw in well
.  community infections but
not significantly less
antibiotics in intensive care without
changes in mortality
there are those who wanted to see it
differently and instead of doing a
clinical trial they have looked at you globally what
happens in big data when looking at
large databases  data the use of
procalcitonin in many
North American subis and it is seen globally
how they are used in how many antibiotics are
used in this study done so I say very
macro no differences were found and they
were even contrary but when one
reads the small print of the study it is that
the use  of procalcitonin is
being very inadequate, for example, the
vast majority of patients  they have a
single isolated determination that
when it seems that it makes a lot of sense
for decision-making, for example, to
suspend antibiotics, then
I think that in fact the authors
are a journal, well, it seems
important to me to also bring all kinds
of studies to this presentation, he says
our data suggest that
procalcitonin was not implemented the
authority of calcitonin use was
not implemented according to the
protocols that one should really
use it
and they also conclude that programs are necessary
to improve the implementation
of the use of procalcitonin
therefore let's say the message is  This is a
test that has been used from the point
of view that it is useful and used without
criteria or, let's say, in a massive way
and without much further reflection, since it
probably won't help us at all
and in that sense I bring another study that is
also negative but published in  an
obviously very prestigious magazine but
created  or that also teaches us things in
these there are 8,000 patients with
respiratory infections respiratory infections,
as you are going to see now, many
respiratory infections are banal or many are not
even respiratory infections,
so the authors do not find
differences, but when one looks
again at the fine print of the article  Of
the methods, he discovers several striking things.
The first is that they
confess in the methods that these are
doctors who
adhere rigorously to well-
established protocols for the management of patients with
respiratory symptoms in the emergency room,
so that they already use
treatments.  short, which are the ones that
we are currently advocating, and
then it can also be observed in the
graphs that there is very low adherence
to the procalcitonin protocols
and even when one looks at how I say the
fine print, one realizes that it
is really bacterial infections
moderately serious there was only one
20%, with which it is very difficult for you to
demonstrate, except in contexts where
doctors, let's say, do it very badly because they
prescribe antibiotics for asthma,
because logically in these doctors who do not
prescribe antibiotics for asthma, it is
very difficult to find that
procalcitonin is being used  useful
if we arrive at any
biomarker of these environments of
uncertainty and with one with a criterion
and with one pursuing something not also to
mention, I remembered when I read this
article that another one that was published in 2012
in Arcalis of Internal Medicine' where
they compare good  they looked a little
at how procalcitonin was used in real life
and the impact it had and it
was very striking like the
North American doctors this is a very
European test and the North American doctors
adhered much less to the news they
followed the protocols much less
use of
antibiotics depending on the levels
of procalcitonin is also also
I saw that the doctors who were
accustomed to having experience
with procalcitonin followed these protocols more,
let's say, paid more
attention to the procalcitonin values, in
short, than those doctors who
had no experience seemed more knightly,
as it says here, I do
n't use that test  Again, therefore,
I think we must emphasize that the test
depends on how you get up, it will
be useful or not
a little to summarize,
keep in mind
that we cannot blindly apply the challenge
to
any patient, much less remember that
there are patients  who have diagnoses
that in themselves
imply a very prolonged treatment,
for example endocarditis, does not make
sense, therefore asking
the inah for appropriation to make
decisions because you already know that you are going
to give it six weeks in
immunosuppressed patients have been excluded
from most  of the trials therefore
we should not
or at least have when we apply the
if we take into account that
they have not been included in the
clinical seals and then we also understand that
where there is more information is respiratory infections
and remember that in clinical trials
there is a follow-up to the rule this does not
mean that the test does not work this
What it means is that when
interpreting the test we must
read the clinical trial correctly. What
these clinical trials tell us
is that doctors with procalcitonin and
knowing the test are capable of
obtaining the same results with fewer
antibiotics,
I believe that  It is the correct reading of
these clinical trials. Clinical
trials do not tell us that below
zero ten is perfectly safe and that
you have to remove the antibiotic. It is
very important that you remember that, but it is
a test that does help us put fewer
antibiotics at  the patients and
I summarize it a bit in these slides that
you have below
when requesting I have let's say paris from
They will be positive when requesting when
requesting us, it is also important to know
when they request us
when requesting procalcitonin, because
in respiratory infections with the
intention of not administering
antibiotic treatment, that is, I am not
clear if this, let's say, is an epoch
performed with a bacterial infection or it is
simply that there is a lot of contamination
for example or I don't know if this is a
viral pneumonia because we are in the
flu season or it is a bacterial pneumonia
because here procalcitonin can be useful
with quite low cut-off points
of 0-12 also in
respiratory infections with  intention
of making short treatments, clinical
trials outside the scope of the
application are showing more and
more that treatments of 5 and 7 days are
sufficient, but many times,
doctors do not dare to
finish it so short, regretting having
their own oil and razor that  He also
tells you today in 5 days in this patient
they have already given him  The levels have risen to the
point and I think that the means
that the doctors incorporate help us to
incorporate this evidence that we are
seeing in other clinical trials on
biomarkers and here the criteria
would be a decrease greater than 90
percent of the baseline again  a
unit application below 0 12
in sepsis it
is interesting to have an
initial evaluation to monitor.
We have said that it can be prognostic
and if the procalcitonin does not drop and
that can help me manage my
patient, therefore beyond what I
have decided that they are going to give the
patient a treatment of a
certain duration that monitoring of the
first 48 32 hours can also be useful
because the diagnosis of
sepsis is obviously not certain
microbiology takes time some patients
have negative microbiology a
normal procalcitonin before  a
diagnosis of sepsis should make us
reconsider whether they really have
something else sick  and that can be very
useful because perhaps we will arrive thanks
to an alternative diagnosis more
quickly than if we wait and as
I mentioned before in the follow-up, it
has a prognostic value, we
should certainly not repeat it in the
first 24 hours because it is not very
informative, but  If after 48
hours from the start of treatment and
when not to request procalcitonin,
then routinely I already believe that this
is a test that one should always ask themselves
a question
before requesting it and not
routinely incorporate it into their
diagnostic tests before any  fever and do not
request procalcitonin in infections
whose management is independent
bacteremia due to several scams due to
staphylococcus aureus others we manage
it depending on whether it is complicated not
complicated with a
standardized duration of treatment therefore
procalcitonin will not be useful for us do
not waste this resource
therefore in general in any
situation in which n  or foresee jce
implications benefit from
a joint prosthesis chronic osteomyelitis will not
change if it will not change our
our practice do not ask for a
procalcitonin
and well here you have a little summarized
the above
more subjectively I have a clear
diagnosis and I am going to manage the patient
with  regardless I am not going to start
antibiotics in any case
very little time has elapsed since the
initial determination this would have a
caveat you may have a
very low initial determination and repeating the
6 to 12 hours may be very informative
but outside of that normal pct situation
In sepsis that would make us
repeat it, we would not repeat it before
48 hours, if your pc is already very low, you
should not repeat them and if the patient is
seeing well and you already have a very low patient,
so repeating it is not necessary
or if you  You are not going to suspend the
antibiotics for the value of the pcd and a
little here we would have the
slightly opposite situations in which if a  the pc
will influence our
clinical practice and therefore it would be justified to
request it and to finish,
always remember that procalcitonin is never a
substitute for an adequate
clinical evaluation and therefore it always has to
be
interpreted accordingly, you always have to make a
complete evaluation of the patient to
interpret but this is not typical of
procalcitonin after all that
we do every day in medicine
simply remember that this is not a
rigid algorithm in which 0 2
leads me to suspend antibiotics
routinely and the opposite, well
thank you very much thank you
javier  as for your
presentation below we give all
the questions you want to
ask
to do so simply write us in
the box ask you a question
click send and in cardiac surgery
in the postoperative period of these
patients what use would
procalcitonin be because that is just one  a
surgery in which many
e  studies, perhaps because it is a
very repetitive protocolized situation in
which complications are important and
in which other standard biomarkers
such as c-reactive protein remain
elevated for weeks and let's say it with
a very erratic behavior so
that all these patients also have
subsequent leukocytosis in the
immediate postoperative period and so there are
many studies and some of the
fundamental ideas would be that the procalcitonin peak,
if determined 24
hours after the intervention, has a certain
prognostic value.
course to overcome
more complicated
probably because the only thing that
is translating is that the surgery has
been more complex or longer or more
bloody
and then how quickly it descends
how it has that slope, let's say
approximately 24 hours of half-life
after a decrease  a new
elevation on the fourth day by  For example,
the fifth day almost always reflects that
there is a complication and most of
the time infectious, therefore there
is information, let's say that it is a sea
with a useful marker in the management of
these patients and not in the field of
cardiac surgery.  Also in the
specific area of ​​heart transplantation, there are
studies that also show that it
can be useful to distinguish
rejection from infectious complication.
Therefore, if it is an area in which there is a
lot of information and it may be
indicated to monitor patients,
you want it to have  what to ask for the pcr
if you already have a patient
or when you could ask for one or ask or
is it
really good as the pcr is a
biomarker let's say so cheap so
simple I don't dislike having both if
I can play a little bit at interpreting them
at the same time  Actually, in
clinical practice, we usually
have both in parallel.
Most of the time, you observe that the
decrease in procalcitoni  na is
faster than pcr
and sometimes when we also observe
discrepancies, for example, quite
high fish with normal fish,
we will have more to think about inflammatory complications that are
not necessarily beneficial, so
it seems to me that it is good to have
both, not the same as you are also going to
have  routinely of the formula
of leukocytes
and then every few days you would request it
if you want to monitor the
patient in the antibiotic treatment
I believe that a fixed rule should not be established
I believe that I insist that it result is the
clinician must ask with an intention  and
therefore I am not in favor of
routine monitoring of any
patient.
I believe that in the field of
critical patients we have mentioned that
surely in the first 24 hours it will not
be very useful
and from 48 I believe that it sends to
the clinic because if the  The patient
has a good procreation evolution
and worked and they will not be derived from that
determination.  There are changes on your part because it
does not seem to me that it is necessary to do it
if the patient three days later
has a fever again and is worried
again and I ask myself that question again because
then it may be I think that it must be
individualized in all patients
and  I always insist with the intention of
using this test for
diagnostic or therapeutic decisions
[Music]
so roughly you would ask me after
48 hours to see how the patient is and
then around day 5 if you want to have
an antibiotic treatment, something to
say two  Very simple points, yes, it
seems good to me, if the doctor is really going to
use that determination on the fifth day
to suspend the
antibiotic treatment, that is why I insist that
if the doctor is not going to decide
based on that value, it is surely
superfluous to do it to me.  It seems that at 48
hours it is interesting in the
seriously ill because regardless of what you think
you are going to do with a shorter duration of talent,
surely it will be longer.  e After 48
hours no one is going to suspend the
treatment if it has a prognostic value
and you can tell me if the appointment itself
is not decreasing at 48 or 72 hours it
may be suggesting that either I was
wrong in the choice of
antibiotic treatment or there is something
something else that I have not done in the patient or
there is some additional complication he needs
a surgical interaction a drain or
there is something that I have missed then
I think that those 48 72
hours are informative if it is informative in the second
determination is
there any relationship between the
biomarker values ​​and bacterial etiology
even if this question is
interesting
in general and I remember from what I have
read there
are more marked elevations in
infections due to great negatives, for
example in negative program materials
that were not positive and then you also have to
remember a  false negative that
I did not mention in the etiology of
pneumonias when pneumonias are
produced by microorganisms that  We give
atypical mycoplasma and that is because you can
have true pneumonia, it is bacterial
but it is not produced by mycoplasma, for
example, you can have a
very discreet elevation and that is a false
negative in the neuro field,
therefore the pathogen also influences the
en  the levels of protection
thank you all very much for following us
in this webinar we also want to
express our gratitude to russia
the sponsor
amos the questions that could not be
answered today and the questions that come to us
in the recorded version that will
remain in the products will be
answered  and sent to the
address you provide when you registered
for this webinar lastly we encourage you to
share the information from this webinar
with your colleagues via email